President Trump by the way his voiced
support for the Iranian protesters he
tweeted out for major tweets about this
he said many reports of peaceful
protests by Iranian citizens fed up with
the regime's corruption its squandering
of the nation's wealth to fund terrorism
iranian government should respect their
people's rights including the right to
express themselves the world is watching
later big protests in Iran people are
finally getting wise as to how their
money and wealth is being stolen and
squandered on terrorism looks like they
will not take it any longer the USA is
watching very closely for human rights
violations next tweet Iran the number
one state sponsor of terror with
numerous violations of human rights
occurring on an hourly basis has now
closed down the Internet not good and
then finally Iran is failing at every
level despite the terrible deal made
with them probably Obama administration
the great Iranian people have been
repressed for many years they're hungry
for food and for freedom along with
human rights the wealth of Iran is being
looted time for change how ominous with
that we bring on Iran expert Joshi Asma
who has contributed reporting on these
protests to a number of major outlets
and so I brought on Josh to clear this
up because nobody knows anything about
Iran Josh thank you for being here
thanks for having what's going on what
should we know about this so these
protests began late Thursday and they
began rather small they began as an anti
rouhani protests and so Ron is the the
president rouhani is the current rebel
leader president Hassan rouhani this is
a guy who was touted by the Obama
administration as a moderate and he
didn't point out the fact that
executions have skyrocketed under
rouhani attacks acid attacks against
women have skyrocketed this is not a
good guy he's not a moderate the the
whole hardline or moderate dichotomy
just is pure fiction because this is all
we heard from Barack Obama's there's a
moderate in Iran rouhani is a moderate
we should support him to liberalize Iran
that's nonsense you're saying it's
absolute nonsense and the reason why is
every presidential candidate is vetted
by the mullahs there's something called
The Guardian Council and The Guardian
Council of Vettes candidates and we saw
back in 2009
they didn't like a candidate mo savvy
and that's that's why we have the Green
Revolution because the mullahs
suppressed this candidate and they said
that we're only going to put forth
candidates that are vetted and that
subscribe to the Islamist regime toe the
party line to the Islamist line so how
should the United States respond
I think the Trump administration has
been doing a good job so far it's funny
that could just be the the mantra of my
show the sense of the show began I think
the Trump administration has been doing
pretty good so far to be fair I've been
a pretty avid stop Trump critic so I
don't say that lightly he's been doing a
good job nikki Haley spoke earlier today
and she said that we're going to hold an
emergency session at the United Nations
we're going to support the Iranian
people and they've been doing a good job
at not inciting and not giving the
ayatollahs an excuse to make it seem
like there is Western interference blame
all of this on the West it's just the
West stirring up trouble yes and the
ayatollahs were gonna do that anyway and
they have been Khamenei he spoke out for
the first time Tuesday and he blamed the
the enemies of the Iranian regime
so what practically I don't think we're
gonna put boots on the ground but I do
have greater faith in nikki Haley and
Donald Trump to back up their threats
with action something that Barack Obama
never did what materially what tangibly
can the United States do to support this
movement so first and foremost we need
to understand that this movement would
not have happened several years ago the
reason why is because now about 50
million Iranians have access to the
Internet and this revolution if you
could call it that is being fueled by an
app called telegram telegram is huge
irani ins use it it's very Farsi
friendly videos are being uploaded and
right now telegram is being blocked by
the Iranian regime the Iranian regime is
blocking internet in most major cities
that are blocking social media twitter
has been blocked since 2009 and what the
United States needs to do they need to
put pressure on companies like telegram
they need to be pressure on social media
outlets to keep the lines of
communication
open because that's the lifeline of the
of the protest base that is life shut
down the communication this thing I mean
this is all over the country and some of
the most religious cities exactly
there's a city called home and them is
the Shia heartland of Iran this is a
place where in 1962 Ayatollah Khomeini
began his Islamist revolution and you we
had protesters there Friday Friday after
prayer and this is when the people get
riled up this is when the Imams come out
and rile up the people and they went out
in the clerical heartland of the city
and said death that Islamic Republic
death to Khamenei that's like let's go
to Ayatollah exactly to revere on
exactly it could be killed for that they
could be killed and right now in Tehran
450 arrests the regime has already said
that they face they face the death
penalty there's a kill they have to kill
them all they may kill them all or like
they did in 2009 they could torture them
really brutally Wow so speaking of
Ayatollah Khomeini and it's a little
confusing the old guy was Khomeini and
the new guy is commie any comment
comment yeah I don't care
I don't do yeah you know I always
noticed this my lefty friends they
always try to pronounce things very
exaggeratedly native so they'll say you
know like like Muslim you know Pakistan
or something but I don't go to Italian
restaurants and say like ok I'd like to
order the spaghetti and I cut a bone out
a pit father would have been no you just
you know so I like to very
ostentatiously pronounced them in an
anglicized now what their one thing
they're chanting in the streets
according to the reporting that we have
is bring back the Shah the Shah who is
ousted in the Iranian Revolution what
what does that mean it's a way to defy
the regime there is no topic more taboo
in the Islamic Republic of Iran than the
Shah this is this is why we had the 1979
revolution you had Islamist factions you
had the working poor stand up and say we
don't want the autocratic Shah and to be
to be clear the Schad does not have
immense support in Iran and he does not
have him at support
in the iranian exile community it's just
like a screw you basic it's basically
screw you and it's basically a way to
invoke nostalgia for a time in a place
that was better than now to make iran
great again exactly the shot 2018 thank
you Ron great again so the last thing I
want to talk to you about the Obama fans
are taking credit for this and they're
saying look the deal gave them a ton of
money and it exposed weaknesses in their
economy which then led to another
protest which were we still in power we
wouldn't support it all but because
we're not in power well take some credit
for it is this all revisionist
nonsense or is there something to it
it's revisionist nonsense that's what I
thought I'm glad you said there is I
mean check Twitter the probably the most
smug human being on the planet Ben
Rhodes I knew you were gonna say been
raised the smuggest he is he is awful he
was smug in office yeah he was the one
who joked about how he fooled the
American people and they were all a
bunch of rubes yeah
Javad Zarif who is iran's Foreign
Minister he negotiated the Iran nuclear
deal with Kerry he's he was a smartest
man in the room and he fooled he fooled
Americans essentially and what we're
seeing now is we're seeing a backlash by
the Iranian people because Rohani
over-promised yeah as a result of the
nuclear do the nuclear deal he said that
this is going to open up the world the
banking system sanctions relief and he
didn't deliver and Iran is still
impoverished drug drug abuse is up
prostitution is up and these people are
suffering and the Obama administration
did little to alleviate their misery
rouhani has done very little to help the
working poor and bear in mind that the
the regime always blames these sorts of
dissonant movements on the middle or
upper classes right and because they
draw a huge portion of their support
from the working class and that's
because they've made the working class
dependent on the government's and
welfare benefits it's all handouts for
the work all handouts and they expect
blind allegiance in return and this is
very much a working-class revolution it
looks like they started it now
it seems from the reporting I read the
working class started this as an
economic movement and not only later did
the middle classes jump on about
political oppression and suppression but
this began with the with the working
poor in Iran
that's exactly right it began as an anti
rouhani protest that basically they
express their grievances over the lack
of economic growth but it's become an
anti Ayatollah oh it has as of Friday it
became a political movement so it's not
it's right longer it's no longer just
about the regime that happens to be
running the government this is about the
whole governmental system and structure
of Iran they want to tear it all down
Wow
gotta love it it's kind of like in
America we do that sometimes a little
less bloody a little a little more fun
you know we say tear down the
establishment but clearly
anti-establishment movements have spread
even to Iran and maybe the United States
will support it